[Music]
[Music]
reader beware
you're in for a scare
my job is to scare people but in this
master class
i hope to teach you that writing
doesn't have to be scary
[Music]
when you start to write do a complete
outline
i start generally with the ending if i
know the ending
then i can spend the whole book fooling
the reader
i was a really fearful kid and i was oh
sure something was lurking in the garage
now
i can remember that feeling of panic and
i can
bring it back and try to put it into my
books
if you're writing for kids think about
the age of the audience constantly my
big rule
for writing middle grade horror is that
they have to know it's a fantasy
the real world can't interfere there's
no
divorce no guns no one ever dies
once you've established that you can go
pretty far with the scares
writing for teens is kind of the
opposite it has to be very real
they have to believe this is happening
[Music]
i grew up in a very wealthy suburb but
my family was really poor i always felt
like an outsider
i was on the sidelines observing
and that's one reason why i've stayed in
my room writing so much
that's the appeal of writing anyway
you're here creating your own universe
in this master class we're going to talk
about how to go about
getting ideas how i use twists how i'd
come up with cliffhangers
and i'm going to tell you how never to
get writer's block
i will take you through the whole
process and show you that
none of this is scary i'm r.l stein
and this is my master class
you